[Music]
next week America will go to the polls
for the midterm elections and the
Republicans if the polls are correct
seem to be gaining quite a lot of ground
I'm joined Now by Bridget for tazy who
is a columnist for spectator world and a
brilliant podcaster and YouTuber and all
such stuff uh Bridget you think there's
going to be a red wave for the
Republicans do you not I think so so I
think it seems that way that definitely
seems to be the temperature it's you
know I I think it's hard with polls
because
who will pick up the phone to be pulled
and who will actually take a poll and
who's lying and
um but it does the temperature seems to
be
people are mad you know they see it as
kind of a retribution for
for the pandemic policies or mandates in
many cases and this is their way to
extract that vengeance
you think the pandemic is as big a
factor as the economy
I think the economy is a big one too I
mean I think that's a huge I think
that's a huge piece is that people are
worried about the economy things haven't
been great the shelves have been Barren
that gas has been really high there's
and then you have this residual
resentment that still seems to exist
that actually I think was really stoked
by the Atlantic piece about having a
pandemic amnesty it seemed to have the
opposite effect where it reminded people
of all the rage that they still have
for things that happen during during the
pandemic I saw that just for all uh
British listeners who may not have seen
that that was a piece in the Atlantic
saying uh we need to have an amnesty
about covert and forgive each other for
all the fights and arguments we had and
the reaction on social media was
enormous and it was to the effect of
hell no I think was the first summary of
what it was he
yeah I think you have to have
accountability before you you are asking
for forgiveness you have to admit that
things went wrong and
and I don't think that that's really
the case in this instance I don't think
anybody said oh maybe we did we didn't
do any a lot of these things right we
were doing the best we could
um even after we had more information we
could have made some changes earlier
that might have given people relief and
people are mad they they didn't people
died alone people kids last years of
their lives and I think that people are
rightfully still angry about a lot of
the things they felt they had no control
over like being forced into getting a
vaccine or keeping their job when there
wasn't very much scientific evidence to
back that up so there's definitely a
palpable anger and in blue States in
particular I'm in California it seems
like the the moms are mad well I saw a
piece today suggesting that Suburban
mothers are breaking towards Republicans
quite heavily uh in the days leading up
to what do you think that is and is our
actual sort of natural Democrats seem to
be embracing the idea of voting
Republican is that not going on
there does seem to be that for the first
time I mean you can't I know they want
to try and downplay crime you know that
they being the media or people saying oh
this is just people being hysterical but
I live in I have eyes I live people know
what they see with their own eyes and I
live in a blue city that has
progressively become more dangerous
there's more mental illness on every
single corner there's more encampments
everywhere I turn that's not something
I'm just imagining that's something I'm
seeing in real time and I don't think
I'm alone and I think that in blue
States in particular
the kids were locked down and out of
school for the some of the longest
periods of time now we're seeing the
learning delays a lot of the social
delays and this affects people I would
say the lower class is more affected by
this as well a lot of the people that we
claim you know the the liberal claim to
care about they suffered the greatest
people are poor people are not as hell
they're sicker and
so I don't think it's
um I don't think it's weird that people
are looking around and saying I I don't
know what to do but I know whatever I've
been doing is not working so just voting
for the opposite party seems like the
the move we should clarify that you
yourself you'll not pause and you are
politically homeless uh as you called
yourself in a brilliant spectator
article
um uh I mean do you think a lot of
Americans are like you they are they are
without a political tribe uh but they're
extremely Fed Up frustrated and actually
just sort of weirded out by uh the
parties that represent them
I do I think it's tough you you know you
want to there doesn't seem to be a a
principled party although they might
both claim to have the kind of moral
High Ground
And I think that being kind of in the
Wasteland of the center as I call it I I
definitely am taking things more
uh like piecemeal you know it's more
instance by instance and and
I would say that in California it's just
a one-party state so I I'll vote just
read just for some kind of balance for
any kind of balance there's no balance
in California at all so I'm in a
different circumstance and for instance
somewhere in a purple state where my
vote might actually matter in California
it doesn't really matter but I do think
there's I mean we're seeing such close
races in places where it shouldn't be
close like in New York City in Oregon
they might have a governor for the first
time in 40 years who's Republican Oregon
I've anyone who knows anything about
Oregon this is like the most blue hippie
state but you've seen the videos of
what's gone on in Portland over the
years and people when when people are
worried about their safety I think
historically they just vote red I'm I'm
not a policy expert or political expert
but I believe that's usually the trend
a lot of Democrats were quite excited
over the summer because they thought
they were getting a lot of momentum
after the Supreme Court overturned Roe v
Wade do you think they exaggerated uh
how much that meant the American public
uh or did that energy fade or is it now
fading
yeah that was interesting I think they
did get some momentum but I feel like
when they pull people it's like seventh
on the list of things that they are
concerned about I don't actually think
it's very high on the list uh when
you're faced with inflation and again
this is a thing that people want to
downplay but when you're somebody who
counts you know pennies and is working
within a budget you know that your money
isn't going as far you know that that
grocery bill that you get every single
week is not it's costing you more money
you know that the gas commute the gas
for the commute you do is costing you
more this isn't something you're just
imagining and it's even more offensive
when people
are telling you oh don't you're just
being crazy this is inflation isn't
really that bad and the prices aren't
going up and your dollar isn't worth as
much and everything is going up so
people are really feeling that and
that's
I'm sorry but crime and what things are
costing these are you know they affect
people
very personally you know instantly and
personally
it's not like that thing this Theory
over there one thing that strikes me
looking at it as a foreigner looking at
these elections is how odd some of the
Senate candidates are I mean you have
John fetterness who uh had a stroke and
and obviously that's very horrible for
him but it's just quite odd to watch him
carry on even though he clearly can't
talk properly uh campaigning and sort of
not nobody really admitting within his
camp that some things aren't right uh
then you have Herschel Walker who's a
sort of extraordinary character uh very
charismatic but with an extremely
colorful past
um you have Carrie Lake running for
governor as well who's who's quite a
telegenic uh and Loud character what's
going on it feels like Wacky Races to me
yeah they are wacky and I don't I don't
think that people are very happy about
the options you know the the average
person doesn't seem too excited it's
it's hard because you feel I feel like
this is the best we can do there's you
know hundreds of millions of people in
this country and these are the people
that were putting up to lead
and unfortunately I don't think that the
kind of people who want to get into
politics are the people who should be
getting into politics and the people who
should be have no interest in getting
into politics and with you know with
Fetter minutes it feels almost again it
almost feels like a slap in the face
like you're just supposed you know we
know you're gonna vote blue no matter
who who we put up there and it feels uh
it's it's like a weird sort of
entitlement that the the party has the
both parties have but in this instance
it's it seems like we know you're going
to vote for this person even though
they're they just had a stroke and have
a hard time talking and then if you note
that
you're somehow an ableist or you're
you're somebody who doesn't care about
the disabled it also feels like um
politics uh people said that they're fed
up with Politics as Usual and so the
American political system has given
people just very abnormal
politicians and that's not necessarily
what people wanted is it
no and yes I mean I guess we get the the
leaders we deserve isn't that the
expression you know I I know that people
wanted the change the the the wrecking
ball that was Trump people liked that he
came in and he and he exposed a lot of
I mean everything for on all sides for
everything that it is and now with Biden
it was I don't know if it was like this
sense of returning back to some normal
but it hasn't been normal at all it's
been strange and unsettling in a
different kind of way and then you have
like you said Herschel Walker and all
these people that it feels like people
are having to put aside their principles
because the culture war is so much more
important than whatever your principles
might be so okay he even if you're
pro-life and you find out that he paid
for an abortion Herschel Walker you're
still gonna vote for that person because
having control of the Senate is more
important than whatever your personal
principles might be in regards to that
that person who's running
and when you're doing that it's like I
mean of course you're gonna get
candidates who are weird if people are
just saying I don't my own principles be
damned I'm I'm it's all about power and
in in some respects it is
you sometimes in your writing and uh in
your broadcast you sound in a sort of
state of despair about America is that
getting worse uh over these midterms or
or are you actually beginning to find a
bit of Hope
um
you know I'm in despair
for different reasons more I'm more
concerned with everyone's mental health
and the addiction and the deaths of
Despair and
the trickle-down effect of a lot of
all of this Insanity you know the the
the div just how divided we are just
everybody's spending too much time
online the lack of Grace and compassion
that we have for one another we had Paul
Pelosi get attacked there's conspiracy
theories everywhere people don't trust
anything and I understand why and then
you have people laughing about it but
people on both sides do this when
there's political violence or sweep it
under the rug and that seems to be the
self-fulfilling prophecy that keeps on
escalating and I'm not I'm not sure
where the bottom is to that you know it
feels like
even in California it feels like
California needs to hit rock bottom
before it can kind of start recovering
but America feels that way too although
parts of it seem
like they're more behind other places
where it feels just a bit out of control
well there are still great Americans
Like You Bridget so thank you very much
thank you